et lorient 4 mois est l'une des vedettes
de la pièce de théâtre baptisée b b où
tout peut arriver aux acteurs sont
jeunes mais évolue de jour en jour alors
ou début des répétitions il y en a qui
marchait pas et qui aujourd'hui marche
donc là ça change toute la donne
cette pièce expérimental destiné aux
adultes est une réflexion à voix haute
sur la grande place que prend un si
petit être on y aborde le stress la
fatigue les tensions vécues par les
parents et même l'arrivée d'un enfant
issu d'un viol sont pas des thèmes
nécessairement qt parce qu'on se dit
rabbin spectacle avec des enfants avec
des bébés sur scène ça va être mignon
mais je veux pas que ce soit uniquement
dans cette production
les parents jouent avec leur propre
progéniture c'est d'abord et avant tout
le bien-être des quatre poupon âgé de 4
mois un an qui demeure la priorité
zhu parrain le moment où vous sentez que
votre enfant et il est pas bien ou un
mal à l'aise ou sent pas bien on arrête
on arrête le juste un jeu
si je joue je suis en état de jeu donc
moi ce que je fais confiance aux autres
parents etc les autres parents qui
prennent la décision pour moi si mon
fils pleure trop
ils viennent de le porter pour donner un
coup de pouce aux parents le comédien
jacques l'heureux en coulisse veille au
soin des petits seins et laura thèmes
chauds et en arrière dans le bar des
bébés fut le gardien pour accommoder les
petits acteurs
les représentations ont lieu à midi
parce qu'après c'est l'heure de la
sieste d'un repos bien mérité ici julie
jasmin boudreau radio canada montréal